foreign
so I'm driving around looking for a
place to uh move our Friday night
evening services but look at this those
of you logging on I want you to stay
with me look at this this is a mosque
this is a mosque every Friday they have
they they pack the mosque out they're
even having to use open grass area to
fit more cars for parking I want you to
see this how easy it is for Muslims to
gather together in prayer because they
have a culture of prayer that here is
Muslims and they gather together in
prayer
they have a culture of prayer looking at
Allah Allah my goodness look at this
Muslim security guard
how you doing there
God bless you
look at this unbelievable look at this
packed this is a house of prayer to
Allah a house of prayer to Allah it is
packed
they have to park you know on other
property I'm so grieved by this when I
saw that
my stomach kind of tightened up I felt
that that ignorance and that fear and if
Allah has blessed you with wealth and
you have
built a house
for the sake of Allah Muhammad sallam
tells us
whoever builds for Allah a house
genuinely for the service of the Deen
genuinely to bring the Muslim ummah
together to give them a facility to come
together to worship Allah as an ummah to
bring them together not to separate them
if someone builds a Masjid to separate
people the Quran speaks about that
separation as being something that will
be a driving force for them to lose the
hereafter
but if we build a house
whoever builds the house of Allah a
Masjid for Allah the prophet sallam says
Allah will build for him a house in
Jannah may Allah build for us houses
when you came to Florida to try to find
a location new location for the dean
Center we looked at many
ugly ducklings as you would say and on
your last trip we did find the location
in Valrico which is magnificent I am so
excited for your listeners for your
followers to understand the magnitude of
what this new center will do in the
Tampa area in the Valrico area in
particular it is a very large facility
the facility is almost 35 000 square
feet it is made up of five different
buildings
uh when we went there we were super
excited I think all of us we did kind of
a little preliminary hey this is one of
the spots we're looking at when we went
in we all saw the potential for what
your vision is and your vision which
would be to have the the dean Center to
have your mosque and then also to have
an Athletic Facility school recording
studio and just the vision that you have
to be able to have that in one location
was just amazing we decided to put in an
offer on the property and we're a little
bit taken aback when we found out there
were two other offers on the property so
we were competing with one facility
which was going to be a car wash and
then another facility another buyer was
going to just have a storage facility
now in both of those cases the existing
Church itself was and buildings were
going to be knocked down just flattened
and used the land to rebuild as the
property is also on four acres as you
know
when our offer was presented to the
seller Pastor O who is the president
pastor of the congregation there really
thought wrong and hard about it and
decided that he just felt our mission
your mission with maintaining a place of
worship was so important to them that
they granted us the contract and we've
been moving forward ever since I want to
touch upon uh up on that where you talk
about
um you mentioned that there was there
were two other offers and what they were
talking about tearing the the church
down
completely they were just going to level
the entire church and uh the other
buildings that go with it so the pastor
uh there he was more inclined towards
um having us continue you know it as a
house of worship a mosque and rather
than having it tore down that's amazing
it is absolutely amazing especially in
today's Times where you hear that money
is everything and and you know they
could have closed a little bit earlier
with these other buyers as there are
things that you have to prepare for but
because it was going to be a house of
worship and again this is coming from a
I believe that they're a Baptist Church
and you know you're Muslim and Faith but
they just they just feel that in today's
times that house of worship someplace
where people can go to receive the word
was so much more important than just
getting the money and running and in
today's Times that's that's highly
unusual and it's a testament to you and
what you stand for and what you hope to
build in the community which is what was
presented to them when they were looking
at the competing offers yeah that's
really profound it's really amazing to
hear that uh because and I want my
audience to know that that you know the
the pastor chose you know rather than
having the church tore down totally and
they they actually you know
um wanted to continue as a house of
worship so people have this opportunity
to go ahead and make this a reality
brothers and sisters we're halfway there
this is your brother Eddie from the D
show and alhamdulillah
to build the dean Center a tower center
a Masjid the first of its kind in
America we are halfway there we have
seven hundred thousand dollars left that
must be collected in order to close on
the property
get the tremendous rewards by donating
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you foreign
[Music]